¿Había sido lo suficientemente diplomática en mi correo?
¿Demasiado exigente en mi mensaje de voz?
¿le desagrada a Howard mi propuesta?
¿O solo estoy exagerando?
Quizás soy yo, pensé.
Luego, un día,
yendo por el pasillo, vi a Howard.
Llevaba papeles,
y al verme, se le iluminó la cara.
y me dijo:
"Sara, Tom acaba de enviarme un correo, deberías verlo.
Es una propuesta para reclutar a más mujeres."
(Risas)
"Creo que la idea de Tom es genial
y que deberíamos apoyarlo".
Howard me entrega mi propia propuesta.
Y me explica las ventajas de lo que yo había escrito.
(Risas)
Howard no estaba en contra de reclutar a más mujeres.
Pero necesitaba escuchar de un hombre
por qué era importante hacerlo.
Mientras se desarrollaba la escena, no dije nada,
porque sabía que yo era solo una invitada
en un lugar que no estaba pensado para mí.
Y en vez de cuestionar mi entorno,
me cuestioné a mí misma.
Quería saber cuántas mujeres talentosas que trabajaban largas horas
y comenzaban sus carreras con confianza
eran entrenadas en esta duda que las hacía decir:
"Quizás soy yo".
¿Cómo era eso posible?
¿No estaban mejorando las cosas?
Las oportunidades para las mujeres incrementaron en los últimos 50 años.
Pero durante la década pasada, el progreso se ha detenido.
Los expertos habían identificado el 2059
como el año donde la brecha salarial se cerraría.
Pero en septiembre de este año,
los mismos expertos anunciaron que según los datos recientes
deberían ajustar las expectativas
hasta el año 2119.
(Susurros)
Cien años desde ahora.
Más allá de la brecha salarial,
las mujeres aún están infrarepresentadas en el liderazgo,
reciben menos oportunidades de ser líderes con experiencia
y abandonan antes los sectores de mayor crecimiento,
como la tecnología,
con un 45 % más que los hombres.
Y ellas mencionan la cultura como la razón principal.
¿Qué hemos hecho para afrontar la desigualdad de género?
¿Por qué no está funcionando?
Los empresarios creen que afrontan el problema
porque brindan formación.
USD 8000 millones cuesta un año de formación,
según los estudios de "Harvard Business Review".
Estos estudios creen que la formación no funciona
y que a menudo resulta contraproducente.
Investigaciones a 830 empresas sobre contrataciones y ascensos
durante 30 años
descubrieron que los hombres enviados a hacer formación sobre diversidad
tienden a rebelarse
al contratar y ascender a menos mujeres y minorías.
Otra solución fue pedir a las mujeres que cambiaran su comportamiento,
que fueran firmes.
Que se sentaran a la mesa.
Que negociaran tanto como los hombres.
Y que hicieran más formación.
Las mujeres obtienen la mayoría de los títulos universitarios,
superan a sus colegas en habilidades de liderazgo
y dirigen negocios que superan a la competencia.
No parece que la educación,
habilidades o perspicacia comercial sean el problema.
Ya estamos lo suficiente empoderadas
para causar un impacto en los negocios que estén preparados.
Estos enfoques no mencionan el problema sistémico clave:
Sesgo inconsciente.
(Aplausos)
Todos tenemos sesgos, está bien.
Se alojan en nuestra amígdala,
pasa cuando vamos a trabajar.
El sesgo influye lo mucho que me gustas,
lo que creo que eres capaz de hacer
e incluso cuánto espacio creo que acaparas.
Gracias, en parte, al movimiento Me Too
se ha ampliado la conciencia sobre el sesgo de género.
Pero las historias de acoso que aparecen en los titulares
son solo una parte.
No necesariamente hay que acosar a una mujer para limitar su carrera.
Los mensajes que las mujeres me enviaron no son sobre acoso.
Las toleran en su espacio de trabajo.
Pero no las valoran.
No conozco a nadie que haya dicho:
"¿Sabes que me encanta de mi jefe?
Me tolera muy bien,
me siento muy tolerada".
(Risas)
Para romper la inercia,
tenemos que dar un paso más allá del Me Too
Más allá de ser tolerada como mujer.
Nuestra organización decidió afrontar el problema de dos maneras.
Primero, si todos tenemos sesgos,
los espacios de trabajo deben ser objetivos desde su diseño,
sin tratar de cambiar mentalidades con una formación.
Nuestro equipo identificó más de 100 herramientas culturales
que se pueden ajustar para contrarrestar el impacto del sesgo.
Descubrimos que pequeñas modificaciones pueden llevar a grandes cambios.
Y cuestan mucho menos de USD 8000 millones.
¿Cómo son esas pequeñas modificaciones?
Si se le pide a una mujer indicar su género
antes de completar una solicitud de empleo
o de hacer una prueba de habilidades,
su desempeño será peor que si no se lo hubieran preguntado.
¿Cómo pueden las empresas evitar el sesgo autoestereotipado?
Colocar la casilla sobre género al final de la solicitud.
Segundo ejemplo.
En una encuesta nacional que llevamos a cabo,
el 50 % de los hombres eran más propensos a indicar
que habían recibido múltiples evaluaciones continuas
a lo largo del año anterior.
Lo contrario a una evaluación anual.
Aquí está el motivo de su importancia.
La revista "Fortune" analizó el desempeño de las evaluaciones de las industrias.
Descubrió críticas como esta relacionadas con la personalidad:
["¡Cuida tu tono!"]
pero no con las habilidades de trabajo.
Estas se dieron en 71 de 94 evaluaciones anuales a las mujeres.
De las 83 evaluaciones a los hombres,
las críticas a la personalidad aparecieron dos veces.
Pero en las empresas que llevan a cabo evaluaciones más cortas y frequentes,
evaluaciones semanales de cinco minutos
enfocadas en proyectos específicos,
las críticas desaparecen.
La brecha de desempeño entre hombre y mujeres
casi no existe.
Las evaluaciones anuales confían en impresiones generales
que fomentan el sesgo,
pero las evaluaciones cortas y objetivas
eliminan las impresiones basadas en sentimientos.
Algunas empresas llevan a cabo estas acciones conscientemente
para contrarrestar el impacto del sesgo,
mientras que otras solo hacen buenas publicidades.
Queríamos averiguar quiénes lo están haciendo bien.
Así que hicimos una encuesta en Facebook,
preguntamos a las mujeres
cómo elegían empleos donde serían valoradas.
La respuesta más común que escuchamos fue:
"Lo busco en Google."
Así que lo buscamos en Google.
(Risas)
Buscamos, en específico,"mejores empleos de tecnología para mujeres".
Los resultados mostraron tres listas muy diferentes.
Una empresa que aparece al principio de una lista,
no aparece en otra,
algunas listas no tienen criterio
y otras son publicidades compradas.
Son pagadas.
Tanto los empleados como los empleadores quieren puntos de referencia claros
que van más allá de las buenas intenciones.
La certificación LEED les otorgó a las empresas claridad
sobre la administración ambiental
al planificar los pasos exactos a seguir para conseguir la certificación.
Queríamos que las empresas tuvieran estrategias para la igualdad de género.
Para nuestro segundo acto,
usamos los resultados de las pruebas a las herramientas culturales,
nos asociamos con la Universidad de Washington
y creamos la primera certificación estandarizada
para la igualdad de género en las empresas de EE. UU.
(Aplausos)
Gracias.
Para crear este estándar,
tuvimos que aprender qué importa y qué no.
Descubrimos que lo que importa
no es el porcentaje total de las empleadas mujeres.
O cuántas mujeres participan en el directorio.
A esas se las llama métricas de vanidad.
Pueden comprarse,
mientras que la cultura interna puede estar desequilibrada.
Los factores que importan y que deben medirse
se encuentran bajo la superficie.
Por ejemplo,
incluso en empresas donde la misma cantidad de hombres y mujeres
indicaron que habían tenido acceso a un mentor,
los mentores de los hombres suelen estar en posiciones superiores.
Al revisar los resultados de las encuestas,
los hombres tenían más probabilidades de decir
que podían ser aprendices de algún superior.
Estamos acostumbrados a escuchar sobre la brecha salarial.
Las brechas en oportunidades son igualmente influyentes.
Al evaluar la cultura de una empresa,
medimos las brechas en las experiencias de hombres y mujeres.
Al ser más pequeña la brecha,
mayor igualdad se encuentra en el centro de la cultura.
También buscamos los principios de la cultura del lugar de trabajo
que son más importantes para hombres y mujeres.
Vimos qué tres factores importan a los hombres,
mientras que muchos más les importan a las mujeres.
Solo comparten uno en común.
Los principales para las mujeres son:
Permiso familiar pagado,
cobertura de salud para los empleados,
sentir que sus ideas son escuchadas
y que tienen reconocimiento por ellas.
Estos son algunos de los 188 indicadores
que determinan si una empresa cumple
el estándar cuantitativo para la igualdad en el trabajo.
Con datos que importan.
Estos son los factores para crear una cultura de igualdad que perdure.
No por un mes o un trimestre
sino por años.
¿Adónde nos lleva esto?
Les dicen a las mujeres con frecuencia
"Puedes ser lo que quieras.
Depende de ti."
Las mujeres de color,
con mayor brecha salarial,
lo han escuchado.
Dos tercios de las trabajadoras de sueldo mínimo lo escucharon.
Los trabajadores que no se identifican como hombres o mujeres
y ocultan su identidad en el trabajo
lo han escuchado.
Si ellos pueden escuchar:
"Puedes ser lo que quieras, depende de ti",
creo que es tiempo de que las empresas también lo escuchen.
Eliminar el sesgo en las empresas es una prioridad.
No podemos permitir que se siga ignorando a la mitad de las personas.
Le hemos dado a las empresas un marco para cambios de verdad.
Las empresas pueden ser lo que quieran.
Depende de ellas.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)